My name's Anne-Marie Imafidon,
and I wear
a number of different hats.
I'm the author of She's In CTRL.
Now, Dr Anne-Marie Imafidon, who's
CEO and co-founder of the Stemettes,
which aims to inspire and promote
the next generation of young women
in science, technology,
engineering and maths.
And I do lots of other
different bits and pieces.
The things that land in my inbox,
people are like,
"Hey, there's this show called
Countdown. Have you heard of it?
"Do you want to do the numbers
for a bit?"
It's Dr Anne-Marie Imafidon!
Very nice to have you here.
Er, sure!
Dr Anne-Marie is a computing
and mathematics genius
who speaks five languages.
She got two GCSEs
while still at primary school
and is the president of
the British Science Association.
If it looks like there's a plan,
then that's very interesting
for me to learn.
Are you special?
I don't think so.
I think I... Or I'll put it this
way, I think everyone's special.
I just don't think
most folks have figured out
what that special is.
There's an element of the way
I've been able to take opportunities
and not be afraid to try things
and fail and succeed
that maybe is special. There are
a lot of things I can't do,
a lot of things I don't remember!
Yeah, we've always only been east,
never lived anywhere else.
Like, our whole lives
are centred around here.
I just love the difference.
Like, there's just...
Everybody is here and coexisting
and enjoying life together.
Best place on Earth!
East London. Yay!
I am the eldest of five.
Sadly.
You don't choose it, do you?
No, because if you're first,
you're the guinea pig.
- I have many regrets for that.
- No, you don't!
About 62 different regrets.
So, school was frustrating,
in part because of the repetition.
Education is repetitive,
because that's how most folks learn.
And so it was frustrating -
"We did this last year.
"And I remember
I was doing it last year
"and it really made sense last year,
so we can do something else."
Then it just turned into, "I'm just
going to sit and talk to Tola,
I'm just going to sit
and talk to Michael,
I'm going to sit
and talk to Rebecca."
I realised,
"Oh, she finishes the work early
and then she gets into mischief.
"So we have to make sure
that we see how we can get rid
of that mischievous behaviour."
Every child is gifted and talented
in ways and manners that I may not
know, you may not know.
So let's find out
the talent of each child.
Outside, it was exploration.
It was like, "Let's try this.
"There's a book that we've found
that's done this,"
or, "Your cousin's doing such
and such a subject. Let's try that."
At one point, I did Greek lessons,
did Chinese lessons,
learnt Mandarin.
There were just a lot of
other things that were free
and available outside.
And then also I like devices.
We had a VCR player at home. We had
lots of different things at home.
And I was incredibly curious.
That curiosity and wanting
to understand how that works -
"OK, if that works that way,
what do we do with that? OK..."
So, I was about four
when I took apart the VCR player.
The thing was completely...
No matter what button I pressed,
it gave me something
totally different.
"How does it work? Why does it
always work? How did it know?"
And looking inside
the cassette tape,
you don't find
what you're looking for.
So, yeah, I'm going to go and
have a look inside the VCR player
and maybe try and lift it up
and use other implements
like toy soldiers to...
Completely ruined my VHS.
Very expensive. About two months'
wages. Have you paid me back?
Sorry, Dad.
I have. Yeah, definitely.
I've definitely paid you back.
So, we used to go
to the computer market,
- so it was like second-hand stuff.
- Cheaper.
Yeah, so a lot cheaper, like buying
floppy disks or buying motherboards.
See, then you get
those bits and pieces
and then try and tinker and put them
together and build a whole computer.
Yeah, she would always be tinkering,
till she was nine or 10.
I gave it a go.
When I graduated from Oxford,
the plan was to go
to the City and work.
It ended up being kind of
working on the tech
for the people that were in tech.
I mean, I can say it now, but, yeah,
I'd sit on the computer all day
for free!
Didn't really need to pay me
to do that.
But I enjoyed it, because
I've always been very curious
and always been like, "We can
use technology to solve problems."
And this was like a ready supply
of problems that needed
to be solved with technology.
It's because gender-diverse teams
make better decisions.
I ended up being invited
to speak at a conference
for 3,500 technical women
in one space.
And as someone that's always been
in technical spaces
but never been in
female-majority technical spaces,
it was quite alarming for me,
quite life-affirming, as well,
that, "Wow! I didn't even know
I was in this minority."
It was almost like X-Men.
You're like, "You have powers, too?"
And so I ended up there
and had a bit of
a road to Damascus moment of...
No, I mean, you really are the only
girl in a lot of these spaces,
and that's kind of not OK.
And so I ended up starting Stemettes
as a result of being
at that conference.
The dream is to work
in the space sector.
I am a first-year
aerospace undergraduate.
Biochemistry and, like,
science to technology.
Technology and financial markets.
It can be so isolating.
You can feel so alone
that, actually,
just a little bit of effort
to get folks together pays so many
dividends for what they do next,
for, you know, how they see
themselves, the fact that
they're not the only girl in the
entire world that's ever done this
and will ever do it.
It's a frustration
I do end up having with events
that I'm invited to these days
that are kind of 'manels', right,
where they're not being imaginative
or thought at all about
who they have
contributing to the conversation.
And there was an email I got
literally last week
that had the same thing.
I had to write back and be like,
"Is it me, or do you not have
a single woman here on this email?
"And we're talking about
society in the future?
"And I would have thought that maybe
we might have a couple of women
in society in the future.
"So we might want a little bit
of their experiences now
to be reflected
in what we're discussing.
"Maybe just me, I don't know!"
In the STEM curriculum
at GCSE and at A-level,
there is a lot of male names
codified in.
So if we say, like, I don't know,
Newton's Laws of Motion,
that means Isaac Newton is
inside the curriculum, is something
that everyone has to learn about.
And so we're wanting to just counter
the balance, so that
for every time there's a male name
you have a female
or otherwise name.
So whether it's GPS
and Dr Gladys West,
who did the maths
on the geostatic satellites,
whether it's Hedy Lamarr,
who was a Hollywood actress
and was an incredibly keen physicist
and ended up co-inventing
Wi-Fi or Bluetooth,
Katherine Johnson, who was a
mathematician in the 1960s at NASA,
did the maths by hand on
early space travel or space flight,
like Rosalind Franklin,
the women of Bletchley Park.
There's so many! For every name that
we have already in the curriculum,
let's just put a little bit
of that 'herstory' in alongside it.
And it frustrates me that
we still have a national curriculum,
at least in this country,
that doesn't mention the names
of any of these women.
And we have the audacity to think
that these dead white dudes
with beards are the only people
that have done anything of note.
The audacity.
How dare we!
At the moment, with technology,
we're the entry point
to what folks are calling
the 4th industrial revolution.
So if you line up eight people,
five of them are online
or have a mobile device,
which speaks a lot to
the size and the scale
of what we're talking about
but the fact that
it's not all-inclusive.
There are many reasons
why we're not all fluent in tech.
There's something of
that definition of fluency.
Being able to understand
is different to being able to speak.
It's different to
being able to write.
And it used to be reading,
writing and 'rithmetic,
and now it's reading, writing,
'rithmetic and r'digital.
In access, there's access
to opportunities, but there's also
kind of norms, stereotypes.
The one that's the most frustrating
is that barrier of
who is able and who is capable.
It's built on a lot of
very intentional
kind of social engineering
centuries - if not decades - back,
where if you're a young woman,
for example, in a classroom, if
it's technical, if it's physics,
if it's mathematical
or if it's engineering-related,
the idea that that's something
you might not get just by virtue
of who you are and the fact
that you... It's really hard
for you to actually see
that any other woman has ever done
maths or physics, engineering
or technology before you.
All of that then gets in the way
of building fluency.
But actually, if we solved that,
we would allow so many more people
to build that fluency
and allow so many more people
to then have agency
and also solve so many problems.
I am the new chair
of UD Music Foundation.
UD is here in east London
and is all about opening up
opportunities in a way that folks,
especially from this area,
might not have
seen or observed or be aware
that that is value
that they can bring to this space.
Anne-Marie first came to us,
and she was part of a scheme
called Young Board Members.
Roll it round, roll it round.
Wow! Energy, intelligence, insight,
drive, passion, leadership.
That's how I'd describe her.
The focus on music technology tends
to be embedded within the kind of
songwriting and production process.
We need to build the skill set
that is going to make
people's careers fit for purpose.
She's a detail person
so gets under the bonnet.
That detailed knowledge and insight
on how technology
is changing people's lives -
visionary.
A-Lab or AID Lab is the Artificial
Intelligence Design Laboratory,
and as far as we know,
it's the world's first dedicated
laboratory to bringing together
design with artificial intelligence.
The folks at Royal College of Art,
like, that, that is really,
really cutting-edge. A lot of folks
don't get to see that,
don't even imagine that a lot
of those things are possible
or that that would be
a problem you want to solve.
We look at transforming bio-waste
into new materials and textiles.
I still love the technology. I love
the problems that can be solved.
And I'm also incredibly curious
about things.
Anne-Marie's a member of our council
at the Royal College of Art.
She's a great champion
and supporter of what we do.
Whenever I talk with Anne-Marie,
there's amazing curiosity.
Whereas being able to
have it then choose is brilliant,
and why not be inspired by nature?
There's no holds barred
about asking the questions.
They're very considered questions,
very thoughtful interventions
about what is the direction
of research policy,
why are we doing what we do,
also about how do we make sure
that technology and STEM
is available for everyone,
it represents everyone and brings
everyone into that conversation.
She's really someone who's writing
the future and enabling people
to be part of that future
and write it, as well.
I think I'm very conscious
that I am a young...
..black woman from east London who's
had a very different upbringing
from a lot of people
at these board tables,
who spends a lot of time
with young people.
And so there's a lot of
insights, experiences, stories
that I get to hear that then can be
fed back at those top levels.
And so being able to bring that
to such a wide range of institutions
excites me, because that's kind of
my way of doing the systemic change,
attack from the bottom
and attack from the top.
And that's kind of what I'm doing.
And you've got to learn the system
to be able to change it.
- Hello!
- What should we do?
Hey, let's do that.
In your brand-new home town.
I know! I've a new job
and everything!
Yeah. It's number 17.
I just want you to get the tattoo
or the T-shirt or something.
Or "Number one, first woman."
I think we'll get you
a number one T-shirt.
We'll make you a number one T-shirt.
Am I dancing inside
that there's a woman at the table?
Yes, I'm dancing inside
because, for a lot of folks,
if you can't see it,
you can't be it.
I'm dancing because if she's able
to occupy that position,
who else could occupy
other positions?
Why have I met
so many directors at GCHQ?
Classified information!
Only joking.
You'll have to ask them.
I have a hunch
that in 20 years' time,
when we look back on Anne-Marie,
she will be seen as someone
who has led the charge.
I think she is destined
for even greater things.
I think her dad wants her to be
prime minister. Let's see.
I'd love to be remembered
as being a big part of that move
or that change
towards who is technical,
what does technical look like.
I have no idea what's next.
Also, I'm still curious.
This is basically me
opening the VCR player,
but just in
a slightly different way.
I could literally be
sat here for hours.
Yeah!